[Musik]
ein paar Sachen zu Hause bei mir aus
privat bin ich ja tausend Teile Till und
dann muss ich jetzt hier ein paar Teile
ins Lager bringen hier sowas zum
Beispiel ja kommen wir vielleicht
einfach mit dann müssen wir dieses Jahr
gleich mit aus
2020 hatten wir alle gedacht schlechter
kann es nicht werden 2021 hat es ganz
schön einfach es musste einfach nur
nicht ganz so beschissen werden wieder
vor vielleicht ist es als ja wirklich
besser zu sein als nach einer weltweiten
Pandemie und 2021 so wieso nach und dann
ist doch nicht mal Mitte Januar und er
denkst dir ach du scheiße 2020 war jetzt
immer noch nicht der Tiefpunkt es
startete McDonald's Trump der hat
wirklich noch mal alles gegeben und klar
zu machen ja im Ranking der
furchtbarsten Präsidenten der USA möchte
ich einen Stammplatz auf der Eins haben
sogar george w Bush positioniert sich
gegen Trump george w Bush den habe ich
noch in Erinnerung sie erwärmt des 11
September ein Kinderbuch vorliest und
sein Gesicht nicht verraten hat was er
gerade nicht verstanden hat das mit den
Anschlägen oder das Kinderbuch dieser
george w Bush wirkt neben Donald tr wie
ein intellektueller Gigant
wenn wir von den USA eins in Deutschland
lernen können dann Desinformation ist
die größte Gefahr für Demokratien die es
gibt wir haben das Internet unterschätzt
im Internet fallen sich alle so wie wenn
man Autos fährt und drückt vorne du
Arschloch nur ohne Auto und wenn ich
mich öffentlich verhalten würde wie im
Internet würde ich nach einer Stunde
völlig zu Recht verhaftet ey warte mal
ja deine Meinung ne dir gefällt mir
super und äh hier hier magst du das
sagst du das ja
cool wusstet ihr dass man unsterblich
wird wenn man Heizöl trinkt wirklich war
habe ich im Internet gelesen hier
ist nur lustig bis der erste Rang glaubt
wie zum Beispiel ein völlig
fehlgeleiteter corona-gegner der in
Idar-Oberstein ein Tankstellen Kassierer
tötet weil er kein Ausweg mehr sah in
welcher Echokammer muss man entdecken
dass man sich denkt nee jemanden
erschießen ja das wäre die Lösung im
Sommer kommt eine Flut wie die Existenz
10.000er Menschen zerstört sterben über
200 Leute vor allem in Deutschland und
der finanzielle Schaden beträgt über 29
Milliarden Euro ForscherInnen sind sich
sicher sehr wahrscheinlich ist es auf
den Klimawandel zurückzuführen und die
Bundesregierung macht trotzdem immer
noch zu wenig gegen den Klimawandel sag
nicht ich sondern das stellt schon drei
Monate vor der Flut das
Bundesverfassungsgericht fest die sagen
Leute ihr könnt mich ins Grundgesetz
schreiben ihr möchtet die
Lebensgrundlage von Tieren und Menschen
erhalten und dann so schwache
Klimaschutzziele vereinbaren dass sie
eigentlich sagen
wirklich alle Tiere und Menschen
schützen Umwelt Kritik in Deutschland
verläuft für die Produktion von
Diamanten erst unter sehr viel Druck
besteht aus Kohle etwas Wertvolles
ja und ich weiß es jetzt hier wieder von
Marvin 78 hier drunter schreibt
Deutschland spielt keine Rolle solange
ich China nicht mehr für den Klimaschutz
macht und ja China und die USA und
andere Länder sind ein riesen Problem
aber vielleicht könnte man als
Deutschland aus der besseren Position
argumentieren wenn der pro Kopf Ausstoß
von CO2 niedriger ist als der von China
und darf man das Klima erst schützen
wenn China etwas ändert also dem
chinesischen Präsidenten die Macht geben
der ganzen Welt die Klimapolitik zu
diktieren
komm endlich zu Corona in Deutschland
wird Anfang 2021 wieder gelockt dauert
als gestern morgen mehr zum Glück gibt
es die neue App Clubhaus wisst ihr noch
die neue Social Media App die alle
anderen Apps verdrängt so genau zwei
Wochen noch kürzer ist dann nur der Hype
bei Astra Senica der Impfstoff kommt
raus und vom gefeierten Heiland zum
dubiosen Hütchenspieler braucht Astra
einfach nur ein paar Lieferengpässe sehr
seltene Nebenwirkungen und eine
überforderte Bundesregierung erst ist
Astra nur für unter 65-Jährige empfohlen
dann wurden Lehrer vorgezogen dann im
Stopp dann nur noch für über 60-Jährige
empfohlen aber auch nicht gerne an
Frauen oder an Tagen in denen ein R
vorkommt mittlerweile ist Astra Seneca
so unbeliebt dass es als Pferde
Betäubungsmittel eingesetzt wird wenn
ketaminmangel herrscht weil die
Clubszene wieder alles weggemacht hat
und dann sind wir auch schon bei der
Frage wie toll kann man das verkacken
mit dem Virus im Frühjahr wird der
maskenskandal bekannt wir wissen jetzt
Pandemie losgeht und alle im Lockdown
festsetzen und Google wann ist das alles
vorbei und wie macht man oldschooling
nur wenn viele bei der CDU wie kann man
damit Geld verdienen
von unnötigen Deals zu unnötigen
Politikern und dann sind wir auch schon
bei Olaf Scholz mit dem rechnet keiner
habe ich im Sommer gesagt aber das
stimmt nicht Olaf Scholz hat mit sich
gerechnet und das war eine
Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung wie
wahrscheinlich ist es das Kandidatinnen
und Kandidat von der Konkurrenz noch
schlechter Wahlkampf machen als ich
stellen sich heraus offenbar gab es da
ein Loch an der Matrix die
Ampelkoalition ist geboren SPD und Grüne
wollten an vielen Stellen was völlig
anderes als die FDP und deswegen passt
Ampel super wenn alle Lichter bei einer
Ampel Leuchten wohin fährt man dann
finden wir jetzt die nächsten vier Jahre
raus ach so apropos Update zur EU alles
beim Alten hat den Friedensnobelpreis
immer noch nicht zurückgegeben während
die Staaten fast alles dafür tun ihre
Bevölkerung vor dem Virus zu schützen
tun sie erfolgreich nichts dagegen dass
Menschen auf dem Mittelmeer sterben das
passiert auch an Land der Diktator Luca
schenken kann die EU mit dem 1000
Menschen erpressen weil das Schlimmste
was da hinten jetzt passieren kann
Humanität ist wie viele Menschen tot
sind weiß man nicht genau weil die
Presse keinen Zutritt hat also die
Grenzen sind sicher ich habe nur nicht
mehr so ganz genau die Trennschärfe in
welchem Land eigentlich gerade genau die
Diktatur ist kann man sich freuen das
ist immer noch private Seenotretter gibt
oder Menschen die eine Luftbrücke nach
Kabul organisieren und Menschen die uns
vertraut haben von den Taliban zu retten
um etwas gute Laune zu verbreiten
erinnert ihr euch noch an das Foto des
Jahres vom verkantesten Frachter also
wann immer ihr beim Einparken des
Stoßstange demoliert denkt daran es gibt
da draußen einen Kapitän der so scheiße
gefahren ist dass die halbe
Weltwirtschaft das mitbekommen hat ich
sag mal egal was diesen Mann noch
passiert wenn kurz vor seinem Tod noch
mal der Film seines Lebens an seinem
geistigen Augen vorbeizieht da geht es
richtig lange um Frachter und
Steuervorgänge so kommen wir zum Thema
des Jahres 2021 auf Platz eins der
gesprächs- und streitheben meine
absoluter Blockbuster das Impfen zeig
mir jemanden der dazu keine Meinung hat
und nicht tätowier mir Astra Seneca auf
den Oberarm wir wussten sehr früh es
müssen 85% der Menschen in Deutschland
geimpft werden sonst wird der Winter
scheiße weil dann zu viele auf der
Intensivstation legen was wird also
gesagt ja Leute das ist Buffet ist
eröffnet
so wäre schön wenn euch bedient also ja
aber jeder wie er mag ne also er müsste
da selber wissen
was wäre schön wenn ihr euch impft die
gönnerhafte Geste der Wahlfreiheit passt
ja überhaupt nicht zur Realität
richtiger Satz von Jens Spahn wäre an
der Stelle gewesen
boah [ __ ]
impft euch auf jeden Fall ich habe gar
keinen Bock im Dezember wieder
Dosenravioli zu bunkern
hat man sich wirklich gedacht das
entspricht ja dem gesunden
Menschenverstand sich durch eine Impfung
zu schützen das wird ja jeder
automatisch machen noch blöder als ich
nicht impfen zu lassen ist nur zu
glauben dass ich einfach alle so impfen
lassen das erste was man zum Start der
Impfkampagne gemacht hat war eine
Impfpflicht auszuschließen was sagen wir
denn jetzt Rechtspopulisten wenn die
sagen die Menschen Politiker Lügen eh
alle nee die Lügen nicht die frechen hat
nur ein Versprechen eines nicht so läuft
wie sie dachten ah ja cool lerne Dich
auch über die kleinen Dinge zu freuen
denn immerhin hat Jens Spahn nicht
gesagt dass er sich durch die Impfung in
einen Krokodil verwandelt das hat
nämlich der brasilianische Präsident
bolzenaru tatsächlich genauso gesagt
und dann meinten viele Politiker und
Politiker irgendwann das ist eine
Pandemie der ungeimpften also haben wir
Jens Spahn gefragt okay also wenn sich
jetzt alle impfen lassen würden dann
wäre die vorbei ja
ja
also wer gut wenn sich alle Ostern
lassen wer soll gewusst werden
die über 60-Jährigen
und dann ist Schluss
da lassen und wie lange ist denn so eine
zweifach Impfung wirksam
vier Monate
und ab wann sollte man sich das dritte
Mal impfen lassen
sechs Monaten nach sechs Monaten warum
es wäre sonst zu logisch
wusstet ihr das nicht früher mit dem
Boostern das hat Israel doch zum
Beispiel schon vor Monaten gemacht
Olaf war schön ne und Wahlkampf auch und
dann habe ich das rechte verstanden ein
Grund warum es Ende des Jahres wieder
eng wurde mit Intensivbetten war nicht
das ist nicht genug Betten darf sondern
weil es nicht mehr genug Personal gibt
weil die immer noch mit Almosen bezahlt
werden für viel zu viele Überstunden und
deswegen kündigen oder überlegen zu
kündigen wir fahren also lieber noch mal
die Wirtschaft gegen die Wand und losen
werden es Beatmungsgerät darf als
Pfleger und Pflege anständig zu bezahlen
ja
aber Urlaub war schön oder
ja mein Urlaub war auch schön jetzt wo
Angela Merkel nach 16 Jahren gegangen
ist können wir dann einfach wieder alle
anfangen Politik zu machen wir hatten ja
jetzt 16 Jahre in den Merkel gesagt hat
Leute ich verstehe dass er keinen Bock
auf Politik habt ich mache nur das
Nötigste und wenn umfragen sagen ihr
wollt irgendwas dann machen wir das aber
ansonsten lasse ich euch in Ruhe wenn
man an merke zurückdenkt denkt man
zuerst ja persönlich doch nicht keine
Skandale bescheiden nervt nicht mit
rhetorischen Talent wenn man sich an
ihre Politik erinnert muss man richtig
Kram ah ja was das nochmal gemacht
können wir jetzt wieder anfangen zur
Position zu streiten die vielleicht auch
mal untervulär waren aber von denen man
einfach überzeugt ist so wie damals die
Grünen mit Umweltschutz oder die SPD mit
Mindestlohn oder die FDP mit Christian
Lindner würde gerne ein paar Wörter
streichen für die nächsten vier Jahre
sachzwwege alternativlos
Aufsicht fahren vielen Dank ich
verspreche auf mich erstmal über die
Kleinigkeiten zu freuen zum Beispiel das
Gras legalisiert werden soll
also ich hoffe für uns alle dass wir
dafür nicht zu viel Rasen für 2020
[Musik]
und apropos ihr könnt ja auch mal bitte
Abonnieren den ganzen Kanal einen
kleinen Booster geben am Anfang reichen
mir 420 Abos pro Tag
richtig schlechter Tag